People have been noshing on shrimp since the
beginning of time, but it hasn't always been
an easy catch.
Wild stocks declined in the 20th century.
Shrimp farms emerged to supply what nature
couldn't.
Factories processed the harvest, ensuring an
abundance of ready to eat shrimp for the
freezer. Jumbo shrimp have long been big on
the cocktail circuit.
Today it comes prepped and frozen, complete
with cocktail sauce.
Just unwrap and thaw.
Shrimp cocktail is one of many ready to eat
dishes prepared at this factory in Thailand.
Fresh from the farm, the shrimp undergoes a
quick cold water rinse.
It then rides a perforated conveyor.
Rinse water drains through the holes in the
conveyor to keep the shrimp from becoming
soggy. Still cool.
From the icy bath, the curly crustaceans
spill off the conveyor into plastic baskets.
They weigh each basket and then transfer the
shrimp to a larger tub.
To keep the chill on.
They add crushed ice between loads.
A temperature of ten degrees Celsius or less
must be maintained throughout.
Processing or quality will suffer.
It's now time for the inevitable, the
heading.
Using a metal tool that's like an open
thimble.
Workers pull the heads off the shrimp with a
few quick tugs.
The heading line is a long and busy one.
The headless shrimp.
Now travel to sizing rollers.
The space between the rollers is narrow at
first and wider further down.
As the rollers spin, smaller shrimp fall
through first and the larger ones continue on
to fall through further down.
They accumulate in different piles on
conveyors below.
This separates the shrimp into five size
categories.
Out of the sorter.
An employee samples the shrimp's temperature
to confirm that it remains adequately
chilled. D headed and sorted by size.
These shrimp are now ready to come out of
their shells.
On the shelling line.
Some workers cut the tails off and others
leave them on because there's a market for
both. After they peel away the shell, they
cut out the digestive tract that runs along
the back. It's often referred to as the vein
because it looks like one.
Workers on this line.
Peel and devein.
800 shrimp an hour.
The shrimp then goes to different prep
zones.
At this one, an employee dips tail on shrimp
into an egg mixture and then dredges them in
rice flour. He sends them down the line to
the next worker.
Heroes. The flowered shrimp in net rice
paper.
As you can see.
There's a bit of a trick to this.
He moistens the edges of the rice paper to
seal the wrap.
The result is a spring roll appetizer that
can be frozen until it's ready to be cooked
and served. In another area, a worker
prepares a breaded recipe, again using shrimp
with the tails still on.
This is finger food and with the tails on,
the shrimp will be easier to grip.
He soaks it in seasonings and coats it in
breadcrumbs.
Then he dips it in egg batter and breads it
again.
The second coating of crumbs will give the
shrimp extra crunch when fried.
The tray is now full.
And so it's over to the fry belt.
After a quick trip through hot oil.
The breaded shrimp is perfectly fried.
All the shrimp, including this raw product,
Take a blustery ride through a freezer.
Spread evenly across the conveyor.
They freeze individually rather than in big,
icy clumps.
So you don't have to thaw a whole bunch to
get a few shrimp.
The frozen shrimp falls into waste stations
at the correct amount.
The bottom opens to release them.
An ice glaze will protect them from freezer
burn.
These frozen shrimp products are ready to
leave the factory.
From the freezer to the oven to your taste
buds.
With all the prep work done at the factory,
these frozen shrimp products are quite a
treat. Rice is
an integral part of the Asian diet, so it's
not surprising to find special storage
vessels for it in Thailand.
The traditional container is a rice box, a
covered jar handwoven from bamboo and often
beautifully decorated.
They're also produced as decorative items
for export.
Thai rice boxes started out as ordinary
household containers for cooked sticky rice.
Today, they're sought after handicrafts
produced in a range of sizes for storage of
all kinds or simply for decoration.
Each box is handcrafted from start to
finish.
The artisan begins with thin strips of
bamboo.
He splits the strips with his fingernail to
make them the width required for the box size
he's weaving. He lines up the first few
strips on the floor and holds them steady
with his foot as he weaves strips crosswise
through them in a under one over two
sequence. He continues weaving this pattern
until he produces a square that's large
enough to form the base of the box.
He sprays the base with water to soften up
the bamboo.
This prevents the strips from breaking when
he now bends them upward to begin weaving the
sides of the box.
Once he's completed the sides, he begins
weaving the boxes neck, pulling the strips
laterally in a circular direction.
He alternates folding one strip upward, one
strip downward.
He trims the downward strips, then inserts
the ends through the woven sides.
Next, pulling the strips through the middle.
He fits a bamboo ring over the outside of
the neck, then another along the inside of
the neck, locking the remaining upward
strips in between.
This immobilizes the strips eliminating any
need for nails or glue.
It also adds rigidity, reinforcing the next
round shape.
A quick trim of the remaining strips and the
box is fully constructed.
He then makes a lid using the same materials
and technique.
Next, artisans coat the outside of the box
and lid with a mixture of chalk, glue and
sawdust. They let the coating dry in the sun
for a day or two until the surface becomes
hard and smooth like clay.
Now an artist gets to work.
First applying two base coats of acrylic
paint.
Once the base coats are dry, she places the
box on a turntable and applies a coat of the
background color.
Once that dries, she begins outlining the
design.
Then she fills in the design.
Once that's dry, the fine details.
It's here that you see the artistry emerge.
Once the artwork has dried, they encircle
the neck with a band of rattan, then with
strips of rattan, tie the box to a wooden
stand.
At the base of each corner, they weave the
rattan strips into a decorative pattern.
Not only is the rice box entirely handmade,
the artisans never use templates, never take
measurements. They do it all by eye.
The inside of the box remains bare.
The idea is to see the bamboo and how
skillfully it's woven.
It's a natural, non-toxic surface against
which it's safe to store rice.